لطالما كانت إسبانيا واحدة من أفضل وجهات الجولف في أوروبا ،
ولديها المئات من
الدورات التدريبية مع وجود العديد من أفضلها
في كوستا ديل سول ، هذا الامتداد الضيق من
الساحل يجذب ملايين الزوار
كل صيف ، وفي حين أن البعض قد
يأتي للشمس والرمال والسانجريا
هناك أيضًا عدد مخصص يأتون من
أجل الخليج
ويبرزون من البقية ، وهو أحد
التحديات التي تواجهها جميع الدورات التدريبية التي يمكن
أن توفرها والتي لا
يمتلكها الآخرون في ملعب لاهاتياندا المعاد تصميمه مؤخرًا ، حيث يتمتع لاعبو
الجولف بفرصة الاستمتاع
بالطعام الذي يصنعه أحدهم.  من
أصغر طهاة إسبانيا الحاصلين على نجمة ميشلان
هنا نظرًا لأننا قريبون جدًا من البحر
في ساحل البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​،
يتعين علينا التركيز كثيرًا على المنتجات
التي لدينا في هذه المنطقة وأيضًا القيام
بذلك لأننا داخل نادي غولف
يتعين علينا  قم بنوع من الطعام المريح ،
لا مزيد من الطعام المريح هنا ،
لقد جئنا طماطم مقطعة بشكل لائق ،
وأشخاص اللوز
ليسوا فقط في المطبخ حيث يعمل
العمل على تسخين
ما أعتقد أنه  حقًا مميز حقًا
حول هذا Haul ، كما لو أنني لم أره في
أي مكان آخر حيث يمكنك رؤية
قارتين حتى تتمكن من رؤية إفريقيا
ويمكنك رؤية Rocco gibrato ، لذلك هذا
خاص جدًا
يمكنك أن ترى أنه أحد أفضل الشواطئ
في  كوستا ديل سول
كمحترف تمامًا كما تعلم
أنك تعلم أنني ضربت عنصرين سيئين بالنسبة
للهواة ، إنها فجوة مثيرة جدًا
لأنك تجعلك تتخذ قرارًا
بشأن الاستلقاء في تسديدتك الثانية
أو المرور عبر الخور
الذي خضع له الملعب للتو  تجديد كبير
ولكن هذا ليس المكان الذي
تتوقف فيه خطط إعادة التطوير ، حيث
يتم إنشاء فندق فاخر في
مكان قريب مما قد يساعد في تحويل هذا
الامتداد من الساحل
بالنسبة لنا ، وهو أهم الأشياء
ربما في هذه اللحظة ، لا هذا هو
مجمعنا الفندقي
الذي يمكنك رؤيته  سيكون أحد أفضل
الفنادق في فصل الربيع لأن لدينا مناظر مذهلة للغاية على البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​، والصخور الأفريقية وخلف هذه الفيلا سيكون الفندق في رأيي إنه
مشروع رائع بالنسبة لنا  نحن نعمل
بجد لمحاولة الانتهاء قبل سبتمبر
من العام المقبل
بينما تستمر أعمال البناء
مرة أخرى في المسار ، لا يزال هناك
الكثير من الجولف للعب
بشكل جيد ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ،
نعم ، إنه لأمر مدهش
أن تكون الحركة لا تصدق.
اللون الأخضر الوحيد أو الأخضر المزدوج في
المنطقة ، نعم ،
إن الخضر التي ذكروها هي واحدة
من السمات البارزة لهذه الدورة
التي أعيد تصميمها من قبل كورتيس بومان
سواء كان الطعام في الممرات
أو المناظر أو الخضر ، فهناك
الكثير بالفعل لتبليله  الشهية على طول هذا
الامتداد الساحلي في إسبانيا
أجنبية